l'acadie célèbre un demi siècle pour la
sagouine
je vais juste à bord ce personnage
attachant né de la plume d'antonine
maillet et popularisé sur la scène du
pays de la sagouine des pots louise
imbeault se souvient du lancement du
livre la sagouine aux éditions leméac
en 1971 la sagouine bien sûr a fait une
grande carrière de plusieurs milliers de
représentations
mais cette première là étaient sains
montrent une avec madame bonheur que
légères dans le rôle qui l'a rendu
célèbre
c'est une histoire vraie que je vous
raconte au début ça l'auteure antonine
maillet livrée à elle-même son texte aux
auditeurs de la radio de radio canada
on pouvait alors entendre les monologues
de la sagouine une pauvre femme de
ménage du comté de kent et fils d'un
pêcheur de morue jésus-christ puis
l'auteur raconte ils rôdent à la
sagouine à la comédienne à katyn dû à la
légère et la mise en scène a jugé mme
gallant 7 sawaya kavala ouais je me suis
rendu compte de la qualité du texte
c'est ça qui m'a impressionné le plus
parce que c'est excellent que c'est
l'ancien texte en colline de mort au
départ la pièce de théâtre jouée à
quatre reprises au théâtre des friches
alain de moncton cinquante ans plus tard
il ya la légère a joué la sagouine plus
de trois mille fois en anglais et en
français sur des saints en acadie au
québec et en europe pour s'amender bella
les personnages des lèvres d'antonine
maillet ont également pris vie au pays
de la sagouine à bouctouche depuis 1992
ils comprennent vous savez nous on n'a
qu'à lienz et du français et la sagouine
n'a pas toujours fait l'unanimité
à chaque fin du billet de penser par
exemple le texte reflète un vocabulaire
anciens et des expressions perdu au
cours des années il y avait des puristes
qui trouvaient que vraiment madame mayer
avec la plus qu'à la belle peut-être pu
écrire français plus standard mais
antonella toujours dit c'est la langue
populaire c'est la langue orale ce point
la langue écrite
l'oeuvre a toutefois réussi à voyager au
delà des frontières acadiens
y est devenu source de fierté et à
partir de là l'acadie à travers le
regard de québécois la réception des
québécois s'est mis à regarder autrement
et apprécier autrement la sagouine et là
elle est devenue vraiment là un
archétype acadien un personnage
tellement vivant nous ont dit manquons
jamais encore peu de ça coûte rien
le lot de la sagouine sont remplis
d'humour de sagesse et de référence aux
enjeux de l'époque et c'est quand on est
pas d'avoir un petit chose qui rende
personnes des jeux de savoir qu'avant la
voix ben et on peut dire sur tous les
temps mais c'est une forme d'humour tout
à fait à 4 yens et on était vraiment
chanceux heureux faudra tout le monde y
passe
le personnage de la sagouine n'est plus
interprété de façon régulière depuis
2010 m
toutefois le vrai occupe toujours une
place importante au sein de la
littérature acadienne
antonine maillet avec son grand talent à
créer ce personnage féminin qui a pu se
mettre à côté d'évangéline et offrir
autre chose et voyage à travers le monde
puis en paradis ici isabelle arsenault
radio-canada moncton